Why are there exactly 435 members of the
House of Representatives? It's not set by
the Constitution, but the Permanent Apportionment Act
of 1929. Back then, there were fewer than 250,000
people per district. Today, there are nearly three
quarters of a million. So, it's fair to ask just how
representative the House of Representatives
actually is. James Madison, the father of the
Constitution, would be dubious. The House was to
be where the Representatives of America, in all
its diversity, would come together. But can
one person really speak for 750,000?
Today's average district is larger than any state back
when the Constitution was ratified. So, what can
we do about that? Madison might suggest: increase
the size of the House. In Federalist 56, he uses
the British House of Commons as a model for the
size of the House. Today, the Commons has 650 seats
and works reasonably well. So, maybe we could add
200 more seats to the house without undermining
its ability to legislate. That would make our
House and our government more representative.
To learn more about my new book, "James
Madison: America's First Politician,"
check out the link in the description. Also, let
us know what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.